За наявною у нас інформацією, ворог позначив мене як ціль номер один.
Мою родину як ціль номер два. Вони хочуть знищити Україну
політично, знищивши главу держави.
Такі слова розпачу пролунали з вуст президента України
в перший день повномасштабного вторгнення Росії.
Слова розпачу з вуст людини, яка ще кілька років тому
грала на роялі зі спущеними штанами й без рук…
Володимир Зеленський змінився до невпізнаваності
… із шоумена, який танцює на підборах
… до лідера в часи війни.
Регулярні відеозвернення на селфі-камеру завоювали
не лише увагу, а й прихильність багатьох і в Україні, і у світі.
Політики з різних країн аплодували йому стоячи.
Чимало фахівців зауважують, що секрет успіху Зеленського
як лідера у протистоянні з Росією полягає в тому,
що він говорить і як він це говорить.
Як саме говорить Зеленський? Зараз з'ясуємо.
Аби зіграти роль президента, потрібні, по суті, ті ж навички,
що й для публічних виступів справжнього президента.
Перед тим, як стати президентом, Зеленський досягнув
неабиякого успіху в шоу-бізнесі.
Виграв "Танці з зірками" у 2006 році
… і озвучив ведмедика Паддінгтона в однойменному мультику.
Зеленський став зіркою комедійного серіалу "Слуга народу",
де він зіграв роль шкільного вчителя, якого несподівано
обрали президентом України.
Я переконана, що акторський досвід Зеленського
став для нього великою перевагою.
Уміння показати себе, запам'ятати текст,
прочитати промову так, аби ніхто не здогадався, що читаєш
- такий акторський досвід Зеленського став йому в нагоді,
коли він став лідером України.
Такі навички конче необхідні в епоху цифрових масових комунікацій.
Це саме те, що треба. Треба бути неофіційним,
близьким до людей, треба запам'ятовуватися.
Всі ми тут. Наші військові тут, громадяни, суспільство тут,
всі ми тут.
Сміливе звернення Зеленського, яке він записав разом
з радниками й урядовцями після чуток, що він виїхав за кордон.
Це селфі-відео тривалістю 32 секунди записане на Банковій.
Воно ідеальне для вірусного поширення в соцмережах.
У цьому відео є все, аби воно стало успішним в часи панування
соціальних мереж. Воно коротке, неформальне,
у ньому використана розмовна лексика.
Це те, у чому Зеленський і його команда завжди були успішними.
Зеленський став президентом, тому що вони ефективно
спілкувалися з молодими українцями саме через соціальні мережі.
У 2019 році Зеленський вів незвичну передвиборчу кампанію,
покладаючись на акторські заслуги.
Він давав мало інтерв'ю.
Акцент робився на соцмережі.
Буквально за кілька місяців вони розгорнули кампанію в соцмережах,
використовували Instagram замість популярного серед експертів
"Твіттера". "Твіттер" вони вважали чимось для нудних політиків
і журналістів. "Інстаграм" допомагав достукатися до звичайних людей,
які не надто цікавилися політикою і новинами.
Стратегія виявилася успішною і принесла Зеленському
переконливу перемогу.
Але йому не вдалося виконати одну з головних передвиборчих обіцянок -
зупинити війну на сході України.
А потім з'явилися Pandora Papers. Розслідування міжнародної
спільноти журналістів з'ясувало, що Зеленський мав зв'язки
з офшорними компаніями.
Українцям це не сподобалося, адже президент обіцяв
покінчити з корупцією.
Рейтинг Зеленського опустився до мінімуму напередодні
нового російського вторгнення.
Утім, відтоді підтримка українського лідера зросла до 90%.
Навіть його політичні опоненти визнають, що Зеленський
веде успішну інформаційну кампанію всередині країни,
що його рішення залишатися в Києві було ключовим.
Попри те, що в перші дні здавалося, що Росія захопить
українську столицю за кілька днів, Зеленський сказав,
що йому "потрібна зброя, а не таксі".
"Бути чи не бути". Ви знаєте це шекспірівське питання.
Пам'ятаєте Перл Харбор? Той жахливий ранок 7 грудня 1941,
коли ваше небо почорніло від літаків, що атакували вас.
Канцлере Шольц, зруйнуйте цю стіну!
Від початку війни Зеленський проводить віртуальне турне світом,
закликаючи парламенти різних країн підтримати Україну.
Він повторює ту саму думку, підлаштовуючи
її під кожну окрему аудиторію.
Коли Зеленський звертається до депутатів інших держав,
він успішно вплітає у свої промови ключові елементи національної
історії тієї чи іншої країни. Це робить те, що відбувається
в Україні, ближчим до слухачів.
Зеленському це дійсно вдається.
Німеччина, наприклад,
зробила розворот у зовнішній політиці й погодилися
продавати Україні зброю. Утім, одна з вимог Зеленського
до іноземних лідерів - закрите небо - досі не виконана.
Деякі фахівці кажуть, що Зеленський, можливо, використовує
один з комунікаційних прийомів - навмисне просить більше,
ніж йому можуть дати.
Думаю, він розуміє, що якщо НАТО вступить у війну на боці України,
це буде третя світова.
Тим не менше Зеленський вимагав безпольотної зони над Україною
для захисту від російських бомб.
Американський конгрес не міг на таке піти. Але вони вирішили
надати більше засобів протиповітряного захисту.
Крім українців та західних лідерів у Зеленського є ще одна
цільова аудиторія.
Тому сьогодні я хочу звернутися до всіх громадян Росії.
Не як президент. Я звертаюся до російських громадян
як громадянин України.
Це промова Зеленського напередодні повномасштабного вторгнення Росії.
У ній він протиставляє себе Путіну.
Зеленський кардинально відрізняється від Путіна
в питаннях комунікації. Путін читає годинні лекції
про суперечливі моменти історії Росії та України.
Натомість Зеленському вдається генерувати короткі ідеї,
які привертають увагу й легко розлітаються на цитати.
Зеленський відрізняється від Путіна не лише методами комунікації.
Надмірна маскулінність російського президента -
одна з його знакових рис.
Слово "мачо" чи не найкраще описує образ, який Путін намагається
собі створити. Він прагне позувати без сорочки, на коні,
як чудовий спортсмен, досягати влади над людьми за рахунок
своєї сили. Зеленському це не потрібно. Його поведінку
хотілося б назвати "постмаскулінністю".
Насправді, на мою думку, це просто інший спосіб бути чоловіком
у сучасному світі. Чоловіком, якому не потрібно щохвилини
самостверджуватися.
Нині Зеленський виглядає виснаженим, неголеним,
вразливим, але тим не менш - рішучим.
Ми бачимо в ньому звичайну людину, якій доводиться робити дещо
надзвичайне. Для багатьох це - геройство. Тож він дійсно,
як не дивно, герой саме тому, що не був ним.
Від шоумена до головнокомандувача. Володимир Зеленський
гідно тримається на сцені, виконуючи роль, про яку,
мабуть, ніколи не мріяв.